gonna be a little more chatter right now
about rashad weaver here he is chris
sims number four prospect at the edge
rusher position
pittsburgh panther defensive end rashad
weaver rashad good morning how are you
pal
good morning i'm good you know
just
counting down the days working out doing
what i can to be ready get there for a
rookie mini camp whatever team decides
to you know pick me and
bet on me
gotta be a weird weird time in your life
as you just wait for
this arbitrary
selection where am i going to be living
for the next four years maybe a lot
longer than that how do you deal with
that uncertainty where basically you
look at the map and there's 30 different
cities where you could end up and you're
going to find out just like the rest of
us do when uh when somebody gives you a
phone call coming up here in eight nine
or ten days
yeah i mean honestly like i'm a super
structured person and like to have a
plan and stuff so that's kind of the
stuff i've been stressing over like
where am i moving all this stuff i'm
trying to leave
pittsburgh go back home to florida for a
month then where am i going to go after
that but
um actually team wise you know i know
wherever i get picked it'll be a
blessing and all the work will pay off
so i'm not really worried about what
city but it's just the waiting game
until i get there you know that stresses
me a little bit
like what what is the approach right now
as far as like training and things like
that do you take some time off and try
to just enjoy the next 10 days
or are you still printing it pretty hard
just for all those viewers out there i
want to know you were you were eating
some food while we were on commercial
break you're trying to keep that white
weight up i like that but like yeah
what's your approach right now 10 days
out
yeah no i mean uh after pro day i took
off our pro day was on wednesday i took
the rest of that week off and i got
right back to it uh that upcoming week
um
these past two weeks me jimmy morrissey
and bryce hargrove have been at the
facility with uh coach d from the
strength staff and you know getting in
those those grinding days you know we're
we're putting in work we're going
we're having finishers every day we're
doing all type of stuff you know just
putting in work hitting the field
getting our wind up short sprints long
running
and we're just working because we know
once we get there we're back at the
bottom of the totem pole and we have to
you know
get gain the trust of the coaches and of
the players that are already there one
way or another
let's peel back the curtain a little bit
too rashad was very polite he began to
eat during the break because he saw that
chris was eating he did not realize that
chris wasn't eating chris had his big
giant makeup brush out and he was
digging in because rashad i'm sure you
can see chris that that he it's it's not
a five head it's a six head on chris so
so good on rashad to make sure that he
had time to have a little breakfast
while we were waiting to come back from
break hey rashad i pride myself on my
research i do some high-level research
on the people we have on the show and
here's the best one i got for you your
middle name is awesome rashad capone
weaver tell me about how you got capone
as your middle name
man i might have to throw that on a
jersey one game if they let me do that
yeah my middle name i mean
you know honestly i have super young
parents you know they had me when they
were teens and you know my mom was like
a tomboy when she was in high school and
you know i think she just stumbled
across that from al capone and she liked
it and that's what she threw into my
middle name
it's awesome i love it it's a great name
florio florio loves it he perked up when
he heard that all right this i'm always
intrigued by this rashad of course as
you know i'm a big fan of yours i think
you're without a doubt one of the five
best edge pass rushers in the draft but
like how do you deal
with all it's it's nitpicking time
people are always picking away at your
game how do you deal with all the
negative stuff you hear you know out
there in the media and from certain
scouts in the media and all that type of
stuff
yeah i mean again i mean i appreciate
you i feel like you recognize the game
and
you see what i bring to it and with that
i think it's just kind of people that uh
they're bored they truly don't know what
they're talking about because some of
the stuff you mentioned you know where i
see myself i try not to see um
this is not feedback i get from teams or
coaches it's almost the exact opposite
uh so you know
sometimes you wish you just uh you gotta
notice more about media but then today
media doesn't matter i don't be the ones
calling my phone
on draft day they're not the ones i've
sat in zones with that told me what they
love about my game and stuff like that
so
you know that's what i kind of try to
focus on and over the past couple months
i've unfollowed more and more
draft accounts because uh i feel like i
feel like i don't they don't know what
they're truly talking about at some at
some points and
and again they're not who matters you
know i know they have a job and they
have to try to
guess
what they know best or try to get clicks
and stuff like that but
uh i think it is what it is mike can i
ask one more question just off that real
quick just if you don't mind just i'm
curious too like don't you i just some
of the stuff is crazy like no bend you
know not a twitchy athlete like i i
don't know i your bend is what jumped
out to me i was like this guy really is
great coming around the edge dipping the
shoulder all that do you feel like you
at least answered questions with your
pro day where you put up some pretty not
pretty big numbers where i think people
are going to go whoa wait this guy's
better athlete than i thought
yeah and i think even with that again
with the bend i think
meeting with outside linebacker coaches
dm coaches all that they talk about my
ankle and how i've been for being a 6465
um getting down there my passwords
losing all that type of stuff and again
i'm i'm the first off the line you know
some of the coaches even talk about
sometimes it doesn't look like you're
moving as fast as you are just because
how lengthy you are
and stuff like that but um yeah with
protein i think it went great so i could
have a little faster 40 i'll blame it on
the new turf it was like four inches
tall but everything else was great you
know my agility and my drills and
everything you know i i knocked it out
the water and i think it just got paid
less attention to than if it was
somebody else because you know i told my
agent just doesn't fit the narrative i
mean you know
coming in running a sub sub seven three
cone somebody else does that that they
like uh you know it's gonna be on
twitter for the next month and they're
gonna be blowing it up you know i run a
decent shuttle you know it was a good
shot of other people but i ran faster
shuttles than that in my training you
know i could have ran in the four ones
on my shuttle easily
um
but you know those just don't fit the
narrative to me and what they want to
say about me so i think it just kind of
got swept on their rug
but again you know the people that
matter seen it
hey rashad injuries happen in football
you had the torn acl in 2019. what did
you learn the most about yourself going
through that very grueling and demanding
and challenging rehab to get back to 100
percent
yeah so for me um
i'd say something i always knew about
myself but just even showed it more i'm
super mental mentally tough and you know
it is what it is type of person like it
happens so let's grind but something i
really learned about myself
and grew was my patience you know it
just wasn't my year for me to go be an
all-american and go to the nfl that you
know i just needed to
um you know go with the the game plan
and the timeline of my life and you know
rehab and get better mentally at
football uh physically my body and then
come out in 2020 and take a full
opportunity of every chance given
especially with the code year not
knowing how many games we play
but um all right fun question all right
i mean because i do my research too and
you know of course know what you look
like where'd your blonde hair go man i
thought we were going to be two blondes
on here together
talking paul what the hell happened with
you man
yeah we got the dirt on you
hey i had the blonde this past season
that's the first time i ever did
anything to my hair
again like i don't step out of my
comfort zone that much but i was like
it's covert so no one's going to see me
except for at the game
[Laughter]
if i don't like it that much i can cut
it off
it grew out i got a little bit cut off
every time i went and got a haircut and
it's all gone now okay
it's always jarring when you see a
defensive player especially a defensive
lineman with a number in the teens 17 we
flashed that up there a few times what
what what put you in number 17 as a
defensive end
i mean yeah so i've been playing tackle
football since i was in third grade you
know i started out with tackle football
and all that and you know like a lot of
guys in college or even nfl when you're
younger
you play quarterback you know because
they want the best athlete best player
to have the ball in their hand
and um
[Music]
growing up peyton manning was my
favorite player so i just got one number
under him and i played quarterback my
whole life up until high school so
that's just kind of where i got that
i switched over to a different number in
high school because i played titan at
the end for the first time and then when
i got back to college i just took coach
nardisi as a freshman and i was like
can i have 17. you know let's go back to
the roots where i started wearing when i
was you know a kid playing football
and you know they're making the rule now
outside linebackers might be able to get
that number so hopefully the team drives
me as outside linebacker i can maybe
throw it on if there's not a skill skill
position that'll take it from me yeah i
bet i know i i figured you'd have your
eye on that 17. and i mean can you throw
it can you throw the football a little
bit i'd like to see you throw i can't
picture your big butt dropping back and
being a quarterback
i could throw before these shoulders got
banged up playing d-line yeah i bet i
bet you know i i brought up the
like montez sweat comparison a little
bit when i was doing you know you got a
pro player comparison right who who's
the guy you know in the nfl that you
look at or you model your game at or you
think you're maybe the most similar to
yeah so i mean naturally i just always
go for the big guys you know that
have you know our explosive and adequate
speed but maybe not four fours four five
those two guys so i've i've watched a
lot of you know chandler jones right
that's a
lengthy guy that just you know destroys
guys with his length and
um
is unorthodox with his moves and does
some crazy stuff to utilize his own
skill set
watch some jason pierre paul another big
defensive end that just uh right gets up
the field and causes havoc in the
backfield everyone's favor you know
especially as me growing up jj watt just
because he can play up and down the line
and then he can impact the game on any
play which i feel like i can't you know
he stops to run he gets the quarterback
candy he uh deflects passes which i just
feel like that's all of my skill sets so
those are just a few of the guys you
know i try to take from and
watch rashad you strike me as someone
who is very structured very organized a
man with a plan guy who wants to know
where he is right now where he's going
but for the fact that nobody knows where
you're going in the draft but tell us
what you're going to be doing during the
draft i got a feeling you've got it all
mapped out where you're going to be
who's going to be there where the
phone's going to be
which channel you're going to have on
this tv what food's going to be there
give it give us an idea of what it's
going to look like to be rashad weaver
on draft night
yes i mean i already got my outfit out i
got my outfit ready
i'll be uh down in uh cooper city
florida
uh with my best friend from here uh pet
pit keyshaw my best friend from high
school mom dad sister both sets of
grandparents and my best friends from
high school as parents because we're
having it at his house
i know they're still asking me what kind
of food i haven't decided yet but i know
what the dessert is uh already
and then you know i haven't decided i'm
either not gonna watch it and just wait
for my phone to ring i'm gonna go sit in
another room while they watch it or i'll
be sitting there staring at the screen
sweating um
so
but that's the main game plan all right
so i gotta i mean the main game plan i
wanna give me give me a little scouting
report on the giddy up i want to know
what you're wearing okay let me hear it
come on
this is a surprise okay fine
we'll have a we'll have a
i have our own clothing brand me and my
teammate here called dreams to reality
so i have a nice
shirt on there
um
pair nice pair of shoes to match the
shirt and i'll be relaxing a pair of
shorts uh
some gym shorts to complete the outfit
you know i'll be in nice sunny south
florida yeah okay all right what dessert
like dessert like what are we talking
about there what are we gonna crush
um
the first one list was bundt cake you
know they got this bundt cake place down
there uh
that's just it's amazing but i only have
a few pieces because i'm trying to keep
this weight under control
you see me eating because i have my meal
prep you know that's healthy food
okay
hey rashad we we wish you all the best
and we'll be thinking of you as you're
picked and we can't wait to see where
you end up congratulations to you all
the best to your family it's great you
got all your grandparents it's great
they're going to be able to share that
moment with you tell your mom excellent
selection on the middle name and uh
we'll see where rashad capone weaver
gets drafted coming up here in eight or
nine days thanks rashad all the best to
you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports